there are only three things you can
count on in this world death taxes and
sequels ensure most sequels aren't
really necessary but they aren't always
a bad thing
after a great movie a sequel is like a
second date with our favorite characters
unfortunately we don't always get to
enjoy that sequel even with the
preceding movie explicitly promised
another installment here are movies that
teased sequels that never happened
the amazing spider-man 2 2014 the
amazing spider-man 2 made a lot of
promises it teased both the sequel and a
sinister six spin-off even worse it
ended right in the middle of a backflip
but there were plans for more from
scenes in the actual film to complex and
credit Easter eggs Sony was Manning all
the guns to bring its extended Spidey
universe to life and they probably would
have if Marvel Studios hadn't made Sony
an offer they couldn't refuse spelling
the end for Andrew Garfield and his
friends the two Studios agreed in 2015
to share joint custody of the webslinger
freeing him up to appear alongside his
fellow heroes and Marvel produced films
the part was recast with Tom Holland and
the amazing spider-man 3 never
materialised Godzilla
following the unprecedented success of
the MCU practically every film studio
was eager to cash in with cinematic
universes of their own but virtually
none have had much luck with the
possible exception of legendaries
monster versts 2014's godzilla and 2017
Kong Skull Island were both
well-received and 2019 s Godzilla king
of the monsters looks to continue the
trend with an all-out kaiju brawl but
this success was a long time coming
after 1998 godzilla bombed the big green
lizards big-screen fortunes were
essentially crushed for the better part
of two decades
apparently convinced that this
ill-conceived version of the iconic
beast was something audiences were going
to want to see more of the filmmakers
included a final teaser scene at the
film's climax godzilla lays eggs and our
heroes must destroy all the hatchlings
but the teaser reveals that they missed
one
[Music]
unfortunately the film's poor reception
thanked any chance of a sequel and it
left the door open for legendary to
acquire the rights in 2010 which so far
seems to be working out well kung pow
enter the fist 2002 s kung pow enter the
fist is one of the weirdest films ever
made
comedian Steve Oedekerk began with a
print of the 1976 conclu flick tiger and
crane fist digitally inserted himself
into the lead role added new footage to
expand the plot and gave the world its
first kung-fu fight with a CGI cow
it's crass juvenile and awesome and fans
have been waiting for the sequel teased
in its final scene that plays like a
trailer teasing the ongoing conflict
with the aliens which were revealed to
be the first films villains as well as
the brawl that's sure to ensue when the
kung-fu cow returns for revenge Oedekerk
insisted as late as 2015 that the sequel
was still happening but there hasn't
been a whiff of news since making the
return of the chosen one increasingly
unlikely your days are over mr. Bubba
hotep writer director Don Coscarelli is
best known for the 5 films in his
long-running phantasm series but in 2002
he gave us one of the single weirdest
cult classics ever put to film Bubba
hotep it's the story of an elderly Elvis
Presley who's forced to take action when
his nursing home is terrorized by an
ancient mummy the film's ending seemed
to set up the possibility of future
adventures even teasing the title Bubba
Nosferatu curse of the sheet vampires
for the next installment but as Bubba
fans know there's no way it'll ever
happen it's an unfortunate case of the
film star shooting the sequel down bruce
campbell made it clear in an
Entertainment Weekly interview saying I
killed it I killed it for me I feel that
the first one was a nice little Jim and
you don't have to make a sequel for
everything so that one I'm just going to
let go of course cos Carelli could
always make the film with another star
but as far as fans are concerned without
Campbell
there is no Bubba Hellboy 2 the Golden
Army the 2004 film Hellboy an adaptation
of the cult Dark Horse Comics character
of the same name could have gone several
ways the half human half demon superhero
might have translated very poorly to
film if not for the extreme commitment
of director Guillermo del Toro and star
Ron Perlman
[Applause]
didn't I kill you already the film was a
moderate hit and spawned the 2008 sequel
Hellboy 2 the Golden Army the film
teased further adventures with the
revelation that Liz was pregnant with
twins and del Toro spent the better part
of the next decade struggling to bring
Hellboy 3 to life but the dream
eventually popped the director confirmed
via Twitter in 2017 that he was sorry to
report that the sequel was definitely
not going to happen after an outpouring
of disappointment del Toro clarified
that the door was open for other
filmmakers to move forward with the
property and it looks like Universal is
finally going the reboot route in 2018
imprint Lionsgate announced that a
darker more horror flavored Hellboy
would be released in 2019 with stranger
things david harbour in the title role
airplane 2 the sequel there are a few
comedy classics more beloved in 1980s
airplane the purest example of the goofy
comic sensibilities of the writing team
of David and Jerry Zucker and Jim Abrams
can you fly this plane and land it
surely you can't be serious I am serious
and don't call me Shirley it's an
absolutely relentless wall of gags and
1982's appropriately titled airplane 2
the sequel exceeded expectations even
though it just repeated a lot of the
jokes
[Music]
there seemed to be no reason why captain
Ted striker and crew wouldn't return for
a third go-round and a post-credits
title card promised that airplane 3 was
on the way but the blame for this empty
promise can pretty much be pinned on
Hayes himself years later Hayes revealed
that he'd simply gotten sick of people
pestering him about the forthcoming
picture causing him to back out
he explained you have to understand the
atmosphere at 31 years ago sequels were
frowned upon they were negotiating for
doing airplane 3 and it had really
gotten to me I was being dragged on by
the press a lot when I go to events when
I finally said I'm not going to do it
that was it they didn't do it
[Music]